[Music]
hi
i'm jessica lawson one of the view from
the top student leaders
thank you for joining us for our final
event of the year
on behalf of the leadership team it's
been our greatest honor to serve as the
view from the top student leaders
and to bring you the most diverse
speaker slate in the program's history
it is our hope that you've learned from
and inspired by
these unique stories that were shared on
the virtual stage
thank you to dean levin liz walker and
the rest of the gsb community
for helping us make this year's program
possible and now it is my pleasure to
welcome dean levin to introduce today's
speaker
thank you jessica and before i introduce
today's speaker
i'd just like to take a minute to thank
this year's view from the top team
for putting together an amazing series
adriana gross jessica lawson joy wong
and rex woodbury on behalf of the gsb
community
thank you for all your work this year
and now i am delighted to have the
opportunity
to welcome to shonda brown duckett the
newly appointed president
and ceo of tiaa she was previously the
ceo
of chase consumer banking tashonda
has been recognized widely as a leading
executive
in the finance industry she was named by
fortune as one of the most powerful
women to watch she was named
one of the most powerful women in
banking by american
banker magazine she founded the
rosie and otis brown foundation
in honor of her parents to recognize
people who use
ordinary means to empower and uplift
their communities in extraordinary ways
she was also one of the 16 women
who inspired lebron james's first
shoe for women the nike hfr
lebron 16 and she's now on the board of
directors of the nike corporation
and i we're just looking forward so much
to hearing more about to shonda's
achievements
as a leader in today's conversation with
adrian aguero's
mba class of 2021.
wow to shonda that's quite a resume
there welcome and thank you for joining
us
thank you so much it's a privilege
you know i i woke up on a saturday
morning a few weeks ago
and was thinking do i go to the gym or
not you on the other hand woke up
on a saturday a few weeks ago or the ceo
of tiaa
absolutely and i i
we're just feeling tons of gratitude for
this conversation right now and
i hope you've had a chance to celebrate
let it all sink in a little bit
and again thank you for the work you're
doing it's an incredible organization
impacting folks that really are the
backbone of everything we have
here in the country absolutely
and the success it doesn't come alone
though right
dean levin mentioned otis and rosie
brown yeah
and you said you were on the shoulders
of giants way back when during that move
from the east coast over to texas
how did otis and rosie make this all
happen
well again it's such a privilege to have
the honor to speak with
all of you and um you know you're right
adrian when i
woke up on that saturday i probably did
not get to the gym
um but i will say that i woke
up and continued to be full of gratitude
and
you can't have the moment of being a
ceo of a company like tiao tiaa without
being reflective
and that brings me to you know your
question when you think about otis and
rosie brown
they are my anchor you know they are my
roots
and when i think about what they mean to
me
uh my dad taught me to reach for the
moon and
he would say you know even if you missed
you would be among the stars
and i am still reaching for that moon
uh my mom would always tell me you know
whatever you do
you know you do you do it with
excellence or you don't do it at all
no matter what it is and so those just
life
lessons along the way not just what they
said but what they embodied
not what they embody but what i saw
growing up and all the sacrifices
it's all of that that allows me to be
in the seat that i am today and again
being on the shoulders of my parents and
so many others before me
um has me full of gratitude and a lot of
humility
absolutely and there were a ton of
sacrifices from your parents right you
told the story about
you told the story about driving with
your car
five of you packed in there and
everything in that car so that says
something right
no it does i mean when you think about
it you know i'm first generation
integration and you know it seems so
long ago when we talk about
you know the the course of our society
uh my dad grew up in the segregated
south in louisiana my mother grew up
um in alabama they met in new york but
when we moved to
texas uh my parents packed everything
that we owned so
it was you know three children my mom
and my dad and
everything that we owned which is you
can imagine in a car that's not much
um and i always say that that was a real
moment because when i think about it
you know i started my life in texas
sitting on crates and
when you think about where you've been
and you think about
where you are you can't help but think
through those moments and i think it's
important
that we are okay talking about those
moments
because the reality is it's those
moments that anchor us
it's those moments that teach us empathy
or humility
it's those moments that showed us grit
and tenacity
and so we meet and i've met so many
amazing people along the way
but the real lessons come from those
everyday people and for me that was otis
and rosie brown when i think about their
sacrifice and trying to do the very best
that they could to provide for us
even in moments their best was not
sufficient
it was their best and you know i'm
forever grateful for that
i'm sure they're extremely proud of you
and
you said it yourself right you can't you
can't forget some of these folks that
are making the sacrifices
you've said when you're on the 50th
floor at jpmorgan
it's it's the people that are in the
mail room it's the receptionist
the cooks that's fact the ceiling right
yes and a lot of times people say well
what do you mean
um and again you know being anchored in
history
and when you think about when and how
did my melanin
my complexion enter corporate america
it entered through the halls of janitors
and cooks
and secretaries that was the first
introduction
to our brilliance and so when i i would
say
to to everyone when i would look on the
50th floor and i see rockefeller i would
say you know he couldn't imagine me
being the face
to his bank you know having the
privilege to lead the consumer bank but
you have to give homage to those who
did not have these amazing rented titles
but they showed up with
strong character they showed up with the
level of excellence
they showed up when they weren't really
being seen
and so when i think about where i am
today i think about
those cooks and those janitors i was
just putting cracks in the ceiling
that over time i could exist and so many
people like me
could exist and so i have a lot of
respect
uh to those who've come before me that
were in roles
that truly paved the way and i'm sure
your leadership is
unnoticed by them right you you
literally told stories where you go down
in the mail room and says
yeah it all starts here right absolutely
i mean
you know look when i think about otis
brown or when i think about
so many people specific specifically
people of color
many times we are disproportionately in
those lower wage jobs or we are in those
entry-level jobs
and so it does not escape me that when i
have an opportunity to be a ceo or to be
in a leadership position
to make sure i go and see those
individuals
to make sure that i can talk about the
strategy
in the role that they play and so when i
would go to the mail room
i would tell the the young individuals
that when you see
us talking about earnings or talking
about that client experience
i would say i want you to brush your
shoulders off and know that you had a
role to play
because you started the process you had
to do your job with excellence when
people made their payment in auto
to make sure it went to the proper shoot
so what so it would post on time
and so by connecting them and
understanding that they
matter and that they have a voice and
that they have a role to play
what i get in return is that the people
furthest removed from our results
see their role in our results and what
was so great is after i was you know
telling them how awesome they were i
remember one of the uh
gentlemen looked at me and he was like
you welcome we got you you know
and i just think that's important
because that's otis brown
my dad worked in a warehouse and he's
brilliant
he didn't go to college but he's
brilliant and he taught me so much
and i just think it's important to make
sure that we model
what it means to see everyone not just
in the big town halls
not just in the employee appreciation
notes
but in what we do and how we do it and
taking the time
to engage with those furthest removed is
what
is what really embodies culture and what
i try to do
every day see the unseen and see the
people that really help
um build your company your leadership is
just jumping from the screen right now
like i don't want to like cry 10 minutes
of this interview
so i think we have a quick video to show
how much folks appreciate
your leadership
so inspiring i can't even like i can't
even express it to you
i think it's one thing to be able to
come in this building every saturday
and we're so grateful to be here but to
be able to see all these black
entrepreneurs doing so amazing
but you're the ceo of chase like that's
my thing
oh my god and it's just amazing to see
that you look like me
and you're able to do that and have that
impact so thank you
and i know this was viral a couple years
ago 2019 but
chloe i mean i can't chloe kills it
right then
yeah she's now like my niece i keep in
touch with her
um she she's amazing uh
and you're right it went viral uh
because it was a real
human moment and i think
it touched a cord in the art of
possibility when people can see
themselves
and what it means to be excellent they
can then be reminded that they are
worthy and deserving
of that same level of excellence and i
think that's what
chloe and i represented with the
beautiful words that she
expressed in such a real and human
moment and it was really heartfelt
and i think people people could relate
to it people can understand it
um and i think hopefully it's a it's a
not in the right direction of the work
we still need to
do in corporate america and i think it's
important because when you look at the
stats right and i know this is a
business class so i have to drop a few
stats here
it is stanford after all but i was
looking at the fortune
500 and when we talk about all the work
that we do all the initiatives that are
out there we have to be outcome driven
and the reality is there's only i think
41 women
that are leading a fortune 500. there
are 16
latin x and there were three
african-americans
and so we can talk about all the things
that
um we're doing but we have to ask
ourselves if we believe that talent is
created equally and opportunity is not
it bears out when you look at the shape
um in the profile of those who are
leading fortune 500 companies which says
to me
we still have a lot of work to do and it
it
really i think hits a nerve when you see
the video
like chloe and i having a moment because
it matters
and clearly the outcomes are not bearing
what we believe and what we aspire to be
true as a country
for sure i love the stats and the facts
i think they ground us
the one that i wanted to mention since
you are very vocal on financial equity
and health for
everyone not just leaders yes is the
median
net worth of black single men and women
versus black
single um white men and women i'll i'll
let you share
the information but i think that that's
important to return to the numbers and
remember we
fight for progress we won't progress but
there's still some very
harrowing statistics out there yeah and
i
i think when you look at the numbers you
know
it tells us what all we still have to do
to make sure that there's full inclusion
and equity for all americans and so what
you're referencing
is the median net worth of single black
men and women are like 200 to 300
dollars
versus white men and women which is
around 15 to 28 thousand dollars
and so when you think about that we have
to say what is going on
and we have to take a moment and say
what has to change
and what do we do what are those choke
points that we have to unlock
because clearly as a society as a
as a human race we could not be okay
with those statistics
and we have to know that we can do
better and that surely it cannot be
all of the melanin that's causing these
results it's not the melanin
there's something else that's going on
that we have to
you know leave bowling and be
provocative about you know these stats
but more importantly be bold
about what we can do better to move
forward
as a starting point maybe you mentioned
in a ted talk right we just need to talk
about money period
and you you told the story money's
personal it's
there's a lot of stuff that comes with
it when you bring it up in a
conversation
but you told the story right of your dad
in the 401k
and just the knowledge of knowing that
existed perhaps could have changed the
financial situation
right yeah i mean when i think about
my father and i think about my parents
and i think about all the sacrifices
that they made for us and i remember
after i graduated from college and you
know i was looking at my dad's statement
and to have to tell your father that you
don't have enough
not even close to be able to retire and
what angered me
is that the 401k was for him
but he didn't see it within himself so
the information
or the way in which the information was
shared
he didn't think it was for him and so
when you think about these opportunities
and you think about
minorities participating in the stock
market or understanding the power of
compounding
or you think about you know the home
ownership rates or you think about
small businesses you can go on and on
all of the things that can unlock wealth
generational wealth there's more to it
the information may be out there but can
people see themselves
are we making it where folks do not have
to feel as if
i i didn't go to college so it's not for
me or
this was something that wasn't discussed
and i don't want to seem less smart
and so i think the opportunity for us is
to really make sure
that we tap into not just the
information but how it's presented
and you're right i talk about it um in a
ted talk because i said you know we have
to talk about this without shame or
judgment
you know like no shame no judgment um
it's not where you start is where you
end up and whether it's a dollar a day
or a quarter just get going and get
started because that power of
compounding
and that behavior over time can really
mean the difference when you think about
your wealth but clearly a lot of times
when people see
their finances they associate you know
their their financial situation
to their self-worth and i like to say
your net worth is not
defined does not define your self-worth
and i just think that's so important and
we have to be okay
i like to say you know we know how to
keep it 100 especially
young people but we have to know how to
keep it 700 plus
you know we have to know how to get
started and be okay
you know with where we are but saying
hey we can make these steps to have a
better outcome and a better tomorrow
absolutely it's a great message it's a
scary
i think thought for folks to make that
initial plunge
and hopefully hopefully we can get more
test minorities taking the plunge
understanding as you said the power of
compounding
and hopefully a more financially sound
future for them absolutely
and you know beyond financial equity
it's obviously been
a tough year for a lot of different
reasons i don't want to just ask about
race outright
i think when you were talking to the
mayor of arlington and i know arlington
is super
important place for you you said
something actually which was
it hit me pretty deep which is
extraordinary is kindness
yeah so if we're just kinder with each
other more patient
perhaps that's the starting point to
ending some of these tensions which seem
to be wrapped up in other
you know things the news likes to
highlight no i think you're right
and you know i like to say you know what
it means to be extraordinary are your
ownable assets you know extraordinary
is kindness extraordinary is laughter i
also think
extraordinary is doing the work and
so many times when we have these
conversations particularly around race
or inequality
we want to start in the middle of a
chapter and i think the way in which we
can
unlock and make real progress is to get
proximate
with the history and to really
understand
the structural inequities to really
understand what it means
when you grew up in a segregated south
to really
understand books like first school um
in in the history that we have in our
society that has caused
so many inequalities and it's not again
to make people feel
bad or ashamed but it is to get to the
root
in business as you know in business
school you have to get to the root cause
the root cause and that's what you do in
business when you see something you say
what is the root cause the root cause
analysis and so i think that if we can
get to the root
of the matter and get educated and get
proximate
and do it with a headset of kindness a
headset of saying
i want what you want i want
my children to breathe just like you
want your children to breathe
you know i want a full opportunity just
like you want a full
opportunity and then we do the work and
i do think that if we work on ourselves
and do it with kindness and do it with
the level of curiosity
then it's us that become the people and
positions of power
it is us that can then be that mom
during us at a school and volunteering
and doing the work it is us it is
humanity
that will unlock the progress policies
and everything else will
change when it's the people that decide
that we can do better
and i think kindness is at the heart of
everything that we do
when you think about progress that's
incredible if the people decide
and kindness will be unlocked everything
will follow
so that was the idea that's the work
right that's the good trouble we have to
get into and stay in
it's a fight worth fighting but as you
said it's not new
there have been many people before us
that have engaged in this we need to
learn from those lessons and continue to
work forward
the thing that i think is so powerful
about that um
is that if we're honest with ourselves
we have made progress
and it is easier than it was
for my grandparents it is easier
than it was from those who enslaved into
the country
so progress is slow progress does not go
in a straight line it goes
up and down but it's progress all the
same
and so i think that it's important that
when we are in positions of power
that we understand the platform and that
we understand that it's
more than just delivering on the
financial results
it is about shaping a culture it is
about using our voice
to make real progress in our country and
i think that's good for business it's
good for
community but it's also for me why i
believe i'm in the seat
it is to stay in that good trouble and
to create that art of possibility
um so that more people can ascend and
really see the power that they have but
also be rewarded
with their hard work and effort and so
progress is slow but we we
are making progress and i think we have
to stay hopeful at least i'm hopeful i
have no choice i have a lot of kids
i have to stay hopeful and believe that
they will have better days than i
and those before me under your
leadership i'm sure they will
they'll be leaders themselves very soon
and absolutely
so tashanda i want to end with a couple
questions that
are directly for the class of 2021 they
have 20 days until they graduate
so we'll look we'll look for some advice
from you on a couple different okay
great amazing so personally you know
folks
they love the titles the gold-plated
careers
but as you said earlier you know you you
rent your title and you own
this character right so what advice and
you've made these decisions before
yourself choosing the right position
over money
what advice would you give folks that
are perhaps grappling with that decision
right now
well i'm glad you brought that point
because i do think i want you all to
write down and to know
that you've rent your title you own your
character
so you should show what with your
ownable assets and so when you're
thinking about
the job and you're thinking about the
opportunity what i would say
is make sure that whatever role you take
or whatever position
you know understand the culture
understand you know
who you are understand and know that you
have the power to make progress
and i also think that it's important to
make sure that whatever road you travel
to stay intellectually curious and even
if you
take a role that may not be ideal
understand that there's a lesson in that
moment
there's a lesson in that journey and so
it's not so much about
which job you take or what just make
sure that whatever you decide
stick with it take the lesson you know
and know that
i would rather take those lessons
getting started
so that when you level up you're
prepared because you've been tested
versus running from job to job the
minute it gets a little tough or you
don't like something
then how are you going to grow and then
how are you going to have a perspective
to be able to tell someone else
something along the way so
rent your title on your character when
you think about your role stay curious
stick with it and think about what's the
lesson
that you're supposed to learn and what
is the gift that you're supposed to give
to
that environment strong start
i like all that advice i'm going to
follow myself all right
how about a mentorship so you've
mentioned before
perhaps you don't learn as much as you
think from the person seven levels
you know above you in the c-suite
perhaps it's the people around you
that you should be looking for for the
learnings what did you mean oh my gosh
so the minute we get into corporate
america all of a sudden we're like
i need these mentors that are already in
these big roles
but i like to remind people mentorship
is all around you
it's all around you and what i mean by
that is when you think about who you are
there's so many facets
of you so how could one person
give you that entire gift so i get
mentored by my assistant
she shows me the power of service of how
she shows up on my behalf with
excellence
i am mentored by having this opportunity
with the youth the people that are going
to do amazing things
and so my point is mentorship is all
around you it's in the history books
that you read
it's in the observations of the youth
it's in senior leaders as well but the
most important thing
is to understand that if you are truly
trying to hone your skills
then you should hone that skill of not
limiting who mentors you by their rented
title
but who is showing up in a way that can
teach you something
that can iron your your hone your skill
set in a way that you can be a better
human
and i just think mentorship is all
around us you have to just open up your
eyes and be willing to receive it
in whichever form that it presents
itself
absolutely and i think closely on that
topic around
looking to the folks around you for
leadership and for inspiration
your friends and perhaps your partner as
well
i think we have a couple pictures to
show you sorry
thank you you guys did your work
i love this check those comments there
key to a long relationship
flirt with your husband i love it i love
that
you know beth ford ceo atlanta lake said
that the most important business
decision you make is your partner
yeah i understand you guys have a
wonderful relationship so
what advice would you give the nbas on
their friends and if you want
their partner selection well i i love
this question
because so many times when we think
about
a relationship you may say you know
i want him to do this and i want him to
do that or this or that for me
but it's the matters of the heart and
the reality is i have a man who's
anchored in character
i have a man who believes that his role
is to lighten my load
who understands that i want to impact
the world
and so as a result he's an engineer and
a marine
but he's a stay-at-home dad you know he
runs our family office i like to say
um buddy but you know what i just think
it's about a partnership and it's about
those ownable assets
and so whomever you choose to spend your
time with
whether it's in life or in friendships
think about the character think about
the ownable assets
um because that's really what's going to
you know help you navigate your storms
your ups and your downs
and i'm just incredibly blessed that i
have a partner
who truly is my partner in life and most
importantly
he's on this journey to help me be the
best version of myself that i can
possibly be
and he's additive to who i am and being
able to unlock all of who i
am when it comes to being a mother a
philanthropist an executive
and all the other you know titles that
um
are part of my portfolio that's
incredible
i love to hear that i think it's
wonderful advice um
find someone additive who supports you
who makes absolutely
a person right absolutely absolutely
okay one more on the on the career side
and then we'll give you our final
question so
obviously you took the new rule at tiaa
yes what advice would you give to folks
as they make these decisions perhaps
they love the role they were in before
but now this
opportunity arises what is kind of your
thought process and how do you make
those
decisions yeah it's such a great
question because i
absolutely loved uh my prior role i love
the company
the people i felt like i still had a lot
of runway
um but i also believe in the art of
possibility
and i believe in getting uncomfortable
and clearly
if there was a word to describe you know
2020 it was
uncomfortability but what was beautiful
is when you sit down
in your quiet moment and you ask
yourself you know
are you reaching your highest potential
not from a
title perspective from an impact
perspective
and when i realized that i wanted to be
open to the art of possibility that
maybe
i can show up in a way that could be
even more impactful
tiaa came knocking at the door and now
what i can say
in hindsight of course is that to be
able to be the ceo of tiaa
full circle when i think about my
parents to be able to be the first woman
the third
african-american to to make history in
so many ways
that's impact you know i like to say
sometimes we
you know we say we're trying to crack
the ceiling and i'm like forget the
ceiling just step outside now you're
dealing with the sky
you know sometimes we just have to get
out of our box of comfortability
and know that you know we are we are
worthy
and deserving and taking a risk
is not a risk if your if your objective
is impact
if your objective is something higher
than yourself
then you have to be okay with getting
uncomfortable and then going for it
going forward listen to that quiet voice
do the work be prepared
don't leave when you're frustrated or
mad make sure you have a clear mind and
a clear heart
and and and listen to to what could be
there for you
and be okay with it what's the worst
that can happen
pretty good advice another set of
incredible lines forget the ceiling step
outside it seems like you've practiced
this before
no hey it's just real it's so real you
know i try to i always say model the
behavior you aspire
you know just don't talk about it be
about it and so for me what i'm sharing
with all of you is what i've experienced
you know it's how i make sure that i'm
always stepping into larger and larger
containers
and not feeling that i'm limited you
know and sometimes especially as a woman
as a black woman
those limitations can feel heavy you
know and that's when you have to say
when people
are saying things or maybe marginalizing
you
you know you have to do like when you
receive something in the mail and it's
not
addressed to you you return that to
sender and so
if people are coming for me on things
that are not me or do not define me
i'm not going to own that i'm just going
to politely just return that back to
cinder
because that is not who i am and and
that means i'm i'm limitless
and then that means if i have to step
outside that's what i will do
incredible one last question for you to
sean though we've asked this to all the
speakers this year in this
challenging moment in these tough times
what principles do you rely on as a
leader
wow i mean first my faith is really
important to me
um my character
uh knowing that it's okay to not be okay
um knowing
that this too shall pass
knowing that in our vulnerability can be
the unlock to possibility
and i think as a leader this
notion of being curious
not just from a business sense but i
want to know
you i want to know what motivates you
i want to know what makes your heart
heavy because as a leader
i think if i can show my vulnerability
then i create permission for you to show
yours
and it's in that vulnerability that
allows us to take a breath
and that allows us to no longer wear the
mask you know
paul lawrence dunbar wrote a poem in
1913 we wear the mask
we can take the mask off and then we can
really focus on the work
and i think that's so important when i
think about leadership principles
character curiosity you know being
vulnerable
authentic and just knowing that the goal
for me is to be the best version of
myself
and that's what i expect for everyone
else and in order for you to be the best
version of you
i have to create space for you to do
that unapologetically
thank you so much to shonda for chatting
right now it's been a complete
pleasure what a wonderful message to
leave with we have
two student questions and i know my
classmates are incredible
so they're going to raise the bar even
higher i'm excited to invite them
to join great hi um
hi it is i can't believe i'm talking to
you right now this is amazing um
i worked at jv morgan chase in
operations for the last three and a half
years so i know you
as t thank you t for joining i am
so excited um okay so we talked about
this already a little bit
and so maybe i'll position this question
a little bit more tactically but
one of the things that has always struck
me have been your anecdotes about
leading people of all levels um in you
know an enormous
institution um and the way you've done
that is
to build those relationships in the mail
room etc
so i am pivoting to a career in
hospitality which is a big shift from
operations at jp morgan um and
as someone who's seen you model this
behavior so well i'm wondering what
tactics you could share
about how to how to build that
credibility with those folks when
you know your your meditation levels are
different and your perspectives are
different but you're all critical to the
work
um so yeah i just love your thoughts and
and thanks again
well first of all thank you so much
lauren right is it lauren
okay great well it's so great to meet
you lauren um first i would say
congratulations on deciding that you
want to pivot that's not easy
um i can feel it you're like i don't
know i don't know but you really want to
do it
here's what you need to remember lauren
show up with your ownable assets
what makes you special is that you have
your own story and your own narrative
you worked in operations so you
understand process
you transfer that into hospitality that
is
really important the process the change
management the different roles what
people do
and how that impacts the presentment of
ultimately whatever that
is you have that muscle and so you may
need to just be reminded
that the work that you put in over the
years is preparing you for this moment
understanding the back office and
understanding how important it is
is so critical in hospitality because
you'll see the people that are cleaning
the rooms or preparing the meals
or doing the landscape and you'll
understand that they are
so important to the customer facing
part of the equation and then lastly
bet on yourself and show up with your
character
show up with your intellectual curiosity
show up with your humble spirit
show up with that smile show up with
that level of
i don't know anything about it but i'm
so excited show up with
all of that because that gets that
expression that look you just gave
that's what's warming that's what's
inviting and ultimately that's where
your magic lies that's where your
superpower lies
thank you so much wow i feel so known
in two minutes it's real though it
really is real so good luck to you
you'll be fantastic thank you
i.t it is i um that you are here with us
uh you know like chloe i am in awe and
i'm just so grateful
uh to see you on the screen so i really
appreciate that um i actually have to
give credit to this question to one of
my classmates who inspired it danielle
um and so my question is you know like
sometimes if there is a ceo
who is from an underrepresented
background or who is a woman
or who is a woman q a's fireside chats
etc
often focus on that identity and
i mean we've talked about this already
today and and these questions are
important
but i also imagine that it can be
somewhat draining to have to answer
what it's like to be a black woman in
your role sometimes
and other ceos don't have to do that so
i'm curious to hear from you
like what question do we not ask you
enough
and if you're willing could you answer
that question for us
wow what a powerful question you said
danielle
i gave you that oh well shout out to
danielle and to you chelsea for asking
it
um let me attack it um in a couple of
ways
first and foremost the reality is being
black has
shaped so much of who i am
it has and the reality is
i feel privileged to have the
opportunity
to talk about being black or being a
woman because
i'm trying to get the world to get
proximate to who we are
so that we can change the outcome and
the narrative of what is possible
and to show that we belong
and so i am more than happy
to carry the burden if you will
because it's not for them it's for you
that's what it's for and i know that
so many women and so many black women
still feel invisible
and so if i chose to ignore that
question
or chose to just talk about return on
capital or
sva or earnings
you would still not feel like you're
being seen
and so i just think it's important to
know your audience
and for me i'm very confident in my
ability to perform you can check the
receipts
but what i really want to make sure
is that a chelsea can have a shot and
when there's more than just
roz and i leading a fortune 500 as two
black women
then maybe i won't need to answer those
questions
and to be quite honest if the question
wasn't asked i would bring it up
because i need to make sure that more
women and more
women of color and more people of color
can understand that their voice is
necessary
and required and i cannot water down our
history i cannot water down our story
and the more that i'm okay bringing that
narrative into the boardrooms and into
corporate america
from my hair braids straight to my
changing of glasses to raising a black
boy
all of those narratives are important so
i'm not going to water it down
and in fact i'm going to make sure that
those stories continue to be
to be stated now if you want to ask what
questions people
don't ask that i wish that they would
ask me more of
um
i would just say more about purpose
because again
my performance speaks for itself you
could not
be a leader and not perform period end
of story
but what i want people to really ask me
about
is my why why do i believe i am the one
with the privilege of having this seat
and therefore i get to share more about
purpose
and impact and my purpose is to inspire
others
and if i can share more about who i am
unapologetically
then hopefully i can inspire more people
more women more you know under
privileged or
the voiceless to see that they have a
shot and they have a shot being
unapologetically though
so hopefully that answers the question
definitely does
a very very powerful answer thank you so
much really appreciate it thank you
thank you such a great question
a fantastic question i'm so fortunate my
classmates are incredible
as you've just seen in a small snippet
lucky place to be in here
tashonda we have a lightning round uh to
close
i hope you're prepared for this yes
maybe not but we'll see
we'll see all right i know you're a
basketball family
so we'll start very simple jordan or
lebron
lebron okay i like the decision
i had to righty the speaker bringing
brilliance to the boardroom
i i love lebron but definitely love
jordan as well
so okay um kim mulkey's 40-0 lady bears
from 2011-2012 or the men's national
championship team from this past year
this march madness was crazy it was
great you know wow
both i mean i know i have to choose but
oh my gosh both amazing runs amazing
runs
that's fair i was very happy to see
baylor beat gonzaga personally but
yeah for another day another day better
album
beyonce is dangerously in love or
jay-z's watch the throne
i'm all about the beehive so dangerously
in love i love it
okay should we pay off student debt now
or invest in our retirement savings both
both work to pay down your debt and
always stay invested
awesome last one there's no choice we
just need your answer
so there's a bunch of ex consultants and
bankers and
folks that love their points listening
right now
how should we spend those chase points
what's the best way to do it
i mean i'm all about travel and
hopefully we'll be able to unlock that
and get back
traveling all around the world travel
where's the first place you're going
after this i mean i've
traveled to texas uh so i've had a
little bit of travel and i can't wait to
go back but most importantly
i want to i can't wait to get my kids on
a plane to continue to see the world
um all around the world i just think
it's really important
i'm great to shonda again thank you so
much for this conversation
it's been absolutely incredible well let
me just
close by saying thank you um you have
been a phenomenal interviewer you had me
smiling i'm just
looking at you and looked at all the
bios you all are quite impressive
the future is bright because you all
have made a lot of great choices
and clearly being part of the stanford
family i can't wait to see what you all
do next
um as a family as a village if you will
um but remember to always reach for the
moon because even if you miss you'll be
among the stars
and you know your future is pretty
bright so thank you so much for the time